es sin duda un momento significativo de
la historia Italiana la muerte de Silvio
berluscón y el hombre que marcó la vida
del país durante 30 años con sus
distintas facetas empresario político
una de las personas más ricas del país
fue nombrado Primer Ministro en tres
ocasiones entre 1994 y 2011 y dinamitó
la forma tradicional de hacer política
en Italia fue un precursor de la
política del espectáculo logrando hacer
que la gente hablara de él chocando
muchas veces con chistes de mal gusto
machistas o políticamente incorrectos y
a pesar de todo funcionaba por años
verlos con y logró convencer a los
italianos a pesar de sus excesos sus
escándalos sexuales su condena por
evasión de impuestos a muchos italianos
les gustaba su manera directa de hablar
algo que le daba Aires de autenticidad
de honestidad a lo que decía en un
panorama político percibido como apático
monótono y corrupto a Silvio berlusconi
se le se le celebrará un funeral
nacional en el duomo la catedral de
Milán asistirán entre otros el
presidente italiano Sergio matarela y
Georgia meloni la jefa del gobierno
italiano el próximo miércoles día
declarado jornada de luto nacional aquí
en Italia